Mm.
Diversity is a pretty new term.
Very grateful for it.
It,
it gets to something that is absolutely
real and has been harder to discuss
before it existed.
That said,
I'm not sure I have a perfect
definition.
It recognizes the fact that we are not
singular,
that we are not all identical,
that we have a variation of,
of brands,
of connectivity,
of aptitudes,
of weaknesses,
of blind spots and of sensitivities and
of capabilities.
People on the autism spectrum who are,
who are very functional,
uh,
in my experience,
tend to have extraordinary analytical
skills and also often actually insight
into social interactions.
So long as they're not the ones
participating.
Uh,
and so you have an eye.
I've had a number of autistic students
actually point out to me dynamics that
were emerging in classrooms that I
hadn't yet seen.
And that once they were pointed out,
I could see a,
and these are the same students who have
a very hard time.
You're recognizing when it is or is not
time to speak or get up or walk through
the middle of the classroom and such.
There are a number of ways to be
neurodiverse.
We have names for some conditions that
actually represent,
uh,
ends of continuum.
Dyslexia is,
is a big one.
Um,
these are going to sound like they're
coming out of left field,
but colorblindness left handedness in
each of those cases being what in
evolutionary biology we call the non
dominant phenotype.
So I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a lefty.
That's,
that's the one of those that I belong to
as a group.
And about 10% of people across all
cultures that have been studied are
lefthanded.
It's a persistent,
stable,
rare phenotype,
which suggests that it's adaptive,
that it's persistent,
it's complex and it is,
it provides the different wiring of the
brain associated with being a
lefthander,
uh,
provides benefit in the social group in
which lefthander show up.
We can put together analyses for why
being a lefthander might allow you to
approach a physical problem differently.
That a right hander would have a harder
time solving,
but the different wiring of the brain
allows for different approaches as well.
Similar with colorblindness,
that it might be really easy to say,
well,
okay,
that just is going to give you some,
some ability to see past color and to
see patterns that aren't color-based
perhaps.
But I suspect that there's wiring in the
brain that is associated with
colorblindness that also allows for
enhanced abilities that are different
from those who are colors cited.
Dyslexia for sure.
Right?
Dyslexia is obviously a very modern
condition because writing is a very
modern condition.
So as an evolutionary biologist,
when I say modern,
I mean thousands of years.
Um,
so dyslexia is modern in terms of
thousands of years.
And um,
you know,
language was always about sound and
never about writing until recently.
And so the,
the lesson,
the ability,
it's almost never an inability,
but the lesson,
the ability to process written symbols
into meaning in your head looks to me
like it's in trade off relationship with
the ability to engage in real time in
speech.
And that's not to say that all of us
can't learn through practice to be
better at any number of these skills,
but that being born with what the world
has is calling a deficit is almost
always going to exist in trade off
relationship with some often hidden
strength.
Strength.
Yeah.